[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visual politik fans vor knapp zwei
jahren gegen unser deutschsprachiger
kanal über geopolitik auf sendung und es
kommt mir so vor als wäre es gestern
gewesen der grund warum wir weiterhin
hier sind es natürlich die unterstützung
die zuneigung und vor allem das
vertrauen das er uns in all dieser zeit
entgegengebracht habt insbesondere
möchten wir all unseren wohltätigen
spenden welche diesen kanal aktiv
fördern ein großes lob aussprechen und
wie zu beginn unseres spendenaufrufs
versprochen während wir diesen monat die
zehn großzügigsten von ihnen also hier
kommen sie die top ten der visual
politik.de unterstützer knut brandes
trat alexander radulescu claude können
wären nach hunziker problem brauburger
wehres termes marco oberst ironie witz
egal und zwei edle spender die nicht
öffentlich genannt werden wollten ich
darf mich aber verraten dass eine von
ihnen aus dem malerischen quinto bei
airolo kommt einen grossen applaus der
top ten und natürlich auch allen anderen
unterstützern denn mit eurer
spendenbereitschaft hat ihr wirklich
etwas bewirkt ihr habt uns nicht nur
motivation gegeben sondern auch dafür
gesorgt dass sich alle zuschauer auf
eine entscheidende verbesserung unseres
kanals freuen können ja dank euch habe
ich mich entschieden künftig diese
schicke fliege zu tragen ist das nicht
großartig okay das war nur spaß die
fliege trage ich nur zum heutigen
feierlichen anlass dieser
preisverleihung die entscheidende
verbesserungen die eure spenden
ermöglichen werben ist dass wir ein
video mehr pro woche herausbringen
werden und vielleicht später noch mehr
das wird nicht gleich von heute auf
morgen gehen da wird auch für noch die
passende personelle verstärkung finden
und einarbeiten müssen aber zumindest
haben wir dann euch unter der
voraussetzung dass wir uns auch in
zukunft weiter unterstützt schon eine
perspektive gefunden dieses vorhaben
finanzieren zu können ich denke dass ich
euch daher einen riesen dank nicht nur
im namen der redaktion sondern der
ganzen die sozialpolitik community
aussprechen kann wie immer findet ihr
den link in der beschreibung zu diesem
video über ihn könnt ihr übrigens auch
einfach nur per kreditkarte spenden auch
wenn ihr kein eigenes paypal konto hat
so und nun zu den visual politik awards
für das jahr 2021 vor kurzem haben wir
schon die mtr wars verliehen an jene
politiker welche uns am meisten
enttäuscht haben damit wir uns aber
nicht dauernd vorwerfen lassen müssen
wer sein nur mickrige kritiker die
einfach alle politiker nur pauschal
schlecht machen wollen werden wir euch
heute zeigen dass es in der politik auch
anders geht die idee hinter dem heutigen
video ist ist jene politiker und
institutionen zu hören gegen zwei tagen
ein jahr beste arbeit geleistet haben
denn ja wir glauben dass es nicht nur
wichtig ist kritisch zu sein sondern
auch gute arbeit anzuerkennen und als
vorbild hervorzuheben nur so können wir
lernen zu differenzieren wir werden
heute drei auszeichnungen vergeben deren
reihenfolge jedoch nicht wichtig ist
keiner dieser drei politiker ist besser
als die anderen was jedoch auch gesagt
werden muss dieses jahr war die zahl der
kandidaten in diesem wettbewerb äußerst
klein 2021 hat uns wahrlich nur wenige
gründe für optimismus gelassen drei
erfolgsgeschichten zu finden war also
eine recht schwierige aufgabe wir sind
also unsere protagonisten des jahres
hier kommt die nummer eins
der visual politik award 2021 geht an
die freiheitsbewegungen in argentinien
in den letzten 80 jahren war argentinien
die ein riesiges testlabor für
verschiedenste politische ansätze
philosophien und ideen vor allem für
jene politischen ideen die man lieber
nicht umsetzen sollte wenn man möchte
dass das einem land gutgeht die
politiker dieses landes waren stets wie
ein kontraindikator dafür was man machen
sollte ihre politik war quasi genau das
gegenteil dessen was die erfolgreichsten
länder tun
heute ist argentinien eines der länder
mit den höchsten steuersätzen der welt
es ist eines jener länder die am
stärksten vom welthandel ausgeschlossen
sind und verfügt über einige der
strengsten arbeitsgesetze der welt
argentiniens gesellschaften sind wahre
imperien die öffentlichen haushalte sind
nie ausgeglichen und das land ist
süchtig danach immer wieder zur
gelddruckmaschine zugreifen
das ergebnis kaum hat argentinien eine
krise hinter sich gelassen gerät ist in
eine noch schlimmere begriffe wie
zahlungsausfall wechselkursrisiko
abwertungen und inflation gehören in
diesem südamerikanischen land zum
allgemeinen sprachgebrauch und das alles
ist angesichts der dauermisere kaum
überraschend das land befindet sich seit
mehr als 80 jahren im niedergang und ist
von einem der reichsten und
wohlhabendsten staaten der welt zu einem
der ärmsten abgestiegen
möchtest du ein paar daten mehr als 40
prozent der bevölkerung leben in armut
der durchschnittslohn beträgt kaum mehr
als 300 dollar im monat das
haushaltsdefizit geräte jahr für jahr
außer kontrolle 2021 werden die
auslandsinvestitionen auf den
niedrigsten stand seit mehr als einem
jahrzehnt sein
und sage und schreibe 70 prozent der
jungen argentinier träumen davon das
land zu verlassen erschwerend kommt
hinzu dass die erdrückende inflation
einfach nicht nachlassen will und das in
einem land in denen die
durchschnittliche inflationsrate seit
der gründung seiner zentralbank im jahr
1935 weit über 50 prozent pro jahr
liebe zuschauer diesen für euch wohl
noch unvorstellbar dauerzustand kann man
nur mit einem wort beschreiben verrückt
denn paradoxerweise wurde argentinien
all diesen jahren schon immer zu der
gleichen politik beherrscht mehr
öffentliche ausgaben mehr regulierung
und mit ausnahme einer kurzen zeitspanne
während der männern periode immer mehr
monetäre expansion seit dem jahr 1983
leben die argentinier in einer
demokratie und in 26 dieser letzten 38
jahre waren politiker an der macht
welche die ideologie des peronismus
durchsetzen wollten und die alternativen
dazu waren na ja auch nicht viel besser
herr on is muss ist die suche nach
chancengleichheit die suche nach
sozialer gerechtigkeit die suche nach 0
armut in argentinien mauricio macri
politischer führer gegen den terrorismus
in den besten jahren ist in argentinien
jedoch eine kleine aber wachsende
bewegung mit einem ganz anderen
politischen diskurs und stil und anderen
ideen entstanden die rede ist von den
freiheitsbewegungen wie der koalition
avanza libertad unter der führung von
josé luis es pärt und der koalition la
libertad avanza unter der führung von
hdmi
darum in freiheit leben zu können
argentinische mittelschicht die du mit
steuern und unerträglichen
bürokratischen verfahren ruiniert wirst
bitte verlasse argentinien nicht
diese politischen bewegungen bringen
nicht nur botschaften ideen und reden
hervor die in der politischen landschaft
argentinien ist praktisch beispiellos
sind sondern sie haben es auch geschafft
sich bei den letzten parlamentswahl im
november als landesweit dritte
politische kraft zu positionieren
sie hielten 1,7 millionen stimmen und
konnten damit vier sitze gewinnen 2 für
die stadt buenos aires und zwei für die
provinz buenos aires die beiden
wichtigsten wahlkreise argentiniens und
auch wenn vier von 256 sitzen im
argentinischen kongress nicht als viel
erscheinen mögen so erreichen diese
bewegungen doch etwas sehr wichtiges zum
einen wecken sie die hoffnung 100.000
der argentinier und zum anderen bringen
sie den kongress des landes dazu wohl
jene politik welche argentinien zum land
der ewigen krise gemacht hat deutlich in
frage zu stellen was ist in diesem
halben jahrhundert passiert das aus dem
leuchtturm der kultur der bildung und
des glanzes der mal argentinien war
dieses dekadente land geworden ist
glaubt irgendjemand dass der reale
wechselkurs
131 sein kann wenn er an den börsen
heute bei 200 liegt wenn ja dann bitte
ich dich sie alle an mich zu verkaufen
für alle dollar laste ich habe uns war
so viele wie es gibt und ich werde sie
in einem jahr zu dem von der zentralbank
gezahlten den satz zurück sein
der politische planen dieser bewegung
ist es regulierungen abzubauen die
haushalt auszugleichen die steuern zu
senken und die zentralbank strikt zu
kontrollieren und ja das alles mag noch
ein ferner traum sein aber wenn diese
bewegung schon eines erreicht haben dann
dass der traum von einem wohlhabenden
modernen ag thi nicht ganz verschwindet
deshalb glauben wir dass sie es auf
jeden fall verdient haben mit dem wir so
als politik über 2021 ausgezeichnet
ermuntert und unterstützt zu werben ja
versteht diese auszeichnung auch als
moralische unterstützung denn vergesst
nicht dass die spanischsprachige ausgabe
von visual politik über 2,5 millionen
abonnenten und zehn millionen views pro
monat hat wobei ein großer teil dieser
zuschauer aus lateinamerika kommt und
obwohl es sich hier nicht um eine
individuelle auszeichnung handelt ist es
klar dass die beiden großen politischen
führer kostenlos experte und html eine
besondere erwähnung für ihre leistungen
verdient haben wir drücken ihnen und dem
ganzen ag tischen volk die daumen
da bist du alle politiker wort 2021 geht
an valerie mirza lenski
selensky ist der präsident der ukraine
allein mit dieser information kann ich
mir vorstellen was er jetzt alle denkt
ukrainische kommandeure sagen sie
könnten einer russischen invasion nicht
standhalten tja so sieht's aus zum
zeitpunkt des drehs dieses videos
herrschen an der grenze zwischen
russland oder ukraine höchste spannungen
es wird befürchtet dass russland wieder
einmal in die ukraine einmarschieren
könnte und viele von euch werden denken
dass die residenz die deshalb den preis
verleihen aber die wahrheit ist dass dem
nicht so ist der ukrainische präsident
hat vieles getan was die ukraine auf den
richtigen weg bringen könnte aber wenn
wir das sagen müssen wir verstehen über
was für ein land wie hier sprechen
[Musik]
die ukraine ist das wahrscheinlich
korrupteste land in ganz europa
praktisch die gesamte wirtschaft
befindet sich in den händen eines
kleinen grüppchen von oligarchen die mit
der regierung verbunden sind und es ist
fast unmöglich einen politiker zu finden
der nicht korrupt ist einen preis ein
salewski zu verleihen ist die russische
rolex denn es ist unmöglich so
garantieren dass nicht schon am darauf
folgenden tag eine verwicklung in irgend
einem korruptionsskandal ans tageslicht
kommt tatsächlich gibt es schon heute
hinweise darauf dass dieser mann nicht
ganz sauber ist pandora papers enthüllen
offshore bestände des ukrainischen
präsidenten und seines inneren zirkels
warum also mag sich fragen lehnen wir
uns so weit aus dem fenster und gegen
ihn eine auszeichnung nun zunächst
einmal sind ihm bisher keine gruppen
taten direkt nachgewiesen worden es
stimmt dass selensky unternehmensanteile
im ausland hat tatsächlich so gut wie
seinen gesamten besitz vor seinem
amtsantritt als präsident offen gelegt
nun sind jedoch weitere
unternehmensanteile ansicht gekommen und
in jedem fall ist ist für ihn illegal
offshore firmen zu besitzen wenn man in
der ukraine lebt ist ist allerdings
durchaus verständlich dass man wegen es
ist ein teil seines vermögens außerhalb
des landes schützen möchte einen
notgroschen falls alle stricke reißen
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir über
eines der korruptesten und politisch
installierten länder der welt sprechen
mit anderen worten im moment können wir
nicht bestätigen dass der lenski korrupt
ist was wir jedoch bestätigen können ist
das eher lenski der politiker war der am
härtesten gegen korruption gekämpft hat
selbst wenn er etwas für sich abgezweigt
haben sollte hat er mehr für die ukraine
getan als alle anderen vor ihm und
glaubt mir die ukraine braucht das
wir sprechen hier über das ärmste land
in europa gemessen am pro kopf bip sind
die ukraine so arm wie die bewohner el
salvadors oder turkmenistan und das
liegt daran dass es in diesem land
praktisch unmöglich ist ein
wettbewerbsfähiges unternehmen zu
gründen wenn man nicht mit der regierung
verbandelt ist egal über welche branche
wir reden alles ist in den händen von
organischen und korrupten politikern und
das gilt auch für das ukrainische
militär tatsächlich ist dies einer der
gründe warum putin 2014 fast mühelos in
die ukraine einmarschieren konnte das
land hat er kaum ausgebildete truppen es
war nicht einmal geld dafür da um
stiefel für soldaten zu kaufen es war
immer das gleiche egal welche politische
partei an der macht war egal ob es pro
russische oder proeuropäischen kräfte
waren sie spielten immer das gleiche
spiel das heißt bis selensky kam
ich wende mich an petro poroschenko du
hast mich zu einer debatte eingeladen
und dachte ich würde angst haben und
mich verstecken ich bin nicht wie du im
jahr 2014
bevor er politiker wurde war sein lenski
ein schauspieler er wurde landesweit
bekannt weil er den präsidenten der
ukraine in einer sehr populären
fernsehserie verkörperte ja das stimmt
als er 2009 zur wahl antrat fragten sich
viele ob seine kandidatur ernst oder nur
als kunst performance gemeint war und
sein sieg kam für viele überraschend das
ist so als wenn martin sonneborn zum
bundeskanzler gewählt würde wobei ich
würde das sicher nicht überraschen
versteh mich nicht falsch soll ist weit
davon entfernt der ideale politiker zu
sein und die ukraine ist lichtjahre
davon entfernt ihre korruption zu
beseitigen was aber das jahr 2021 angeht
muss man anerkennen sie haben
ordentliche arbeit geleistet und zwar in
die richtige richtung juni 2021 hat die
regierung zb den kauf und verkauf von
landwirtschaftlichen flächen
liberalisiert bis dahin haben die
restriktiven gesetze des landes dafür
gesorgt dass die legendäre shazam also
schwarzerde die fruchtbaren ackerböden
der ukraine fest in den händen von nur
25 oligarchen blieben aber nicht nur das
wenn es eine sache gibt es weselsky
applaus verdient dann ist es dieses
gesetz das ukrainische parlament
verabschiedet ein gesetz zur begrenzung
des einflusses der oligarchen auf die
politik dieses gesetz schreibt vor dass
sich jeder der eine bestimmte sehr hohen
vermögens größe überschreitet als
organisch registrieren lassen muss und
verbietet diesen organischen die
finanzierung von wahlkämpfen viele
analysten haben das gesetz kritisiert
weil es ihrer meinung nach weit genug
gehe einige haben sogar gesagt dass es
dazu instrumentalisiert werden konnte
politische gegner anzugreifen und es ist
klar dass es noch ein langer weg ist um
die korruption in diesem land zu beenden
dennoch sind dies wichtige schritte in
die richtige richtung sei längst gegen
seine verbündeten sind aber auch die
ersten politiker seit dem ende der
sowjetunion welchem wegweisende
entscheidungen für die ukraine umgesetzt
haben die das land ganz objektiv wird er
jetzt endlich auf eine bessere zukunft
vorbereitet hierzu zählen massive
investitionen ins schul und
gesundheitswesen und in die
infrastruktur
wenn man heute in die ukraine ist sieht
man zum ersten mal dass die gelder
hierfür qualitativ hochwertigen
ergebnissen geführt haben anstatt wie
immer in den taschen der oligarchie zu
versickern so gut wie die jetzt neu
gebauten straßen kannten die ukraine
vorher nur aus dem ausland dies alles
sind sehr wichtige zukunftsinvestitionen
soll das land und deutliche zeichen dass
es der lenski ernst damit meint die
ukraine aus ihrer misere hinaus zu
führen bei all den müssen wir aber auch
auf dem putin faktor hinweisen dass
heißt selensky hat zwei wichtige gründe
die korruption wirklich zu bekämpfen
erstens wenn er es nicht tut werden
ihnen wieder die nato noch die
internationale gemeinschaft unterstützen
zweitens kann es sich die ukraine
einfach schon aus existenz gründen nicht
leisten nicht wettbewerbsfähig zu sein
wenn sie weiterhin in armut versenkt
wird sie sich einfach keine armee
leisten können um sich gegen eine
mögliche putin version verteidigen zu
können habe ich gerade putin version
gesagt ja ich glaube das habe ich gesagt
das ist genauso schön wie green station
aber scherz beiseite es gibt grund zu
der annahme und des elends gegner
präsident sein könnte der den kräne ein
für alle mal verändern wird wolodimir
selensky mit diesem preis wollen wir
deine arbeit im jahr 2020 anerkennen und
die einen grund geben uns im jahr 2022
nicht zu enttäuschen denn du willst dich
doch sicher nicht bei den visual politik
rtl boss 2220 wiederfinden oder also du
weißt was du zu tun hast ich weiß das
sind fast schon presser methoden die die
so alt politiker an den tag legt aber
wenn es doch den menschen dient gut
kommen wir zu unserem nächsten
preisträger last but not least
und der visual politik award
2021 geht an cpg pg
dies ist vielleicht eine der
ungewöhnlichsten auszeichnungen die wir
bei visual politik vergeben haben es ist
keine auszeichnung für einen politiker
oder eine bewegung sondern für eine
handlung abkommen eine institution eine
sehr ungewöhnliche institution wir
stellen vor das cpp das comprehensive
and progress of agri made for transtec
partnership auch bekannt als tv plm
eines der wichtigsten freihandels und
wirtschaftsintegration abkommen der
geschichte ein abkommen das aus den
gescheiterten tbp hervorgegangen ist dem
größten freihandelsabkommen der
geschichte das beinahe ganz
zusammengebrochen wäre als donald trump
beschloss die vereinigten staaten sofort
nach seiner ankunft im weißen haus
aussteigen zu lassen die anderen elf
misst die sender haben sich jedoch vor
allem dank der initiative japans
entschlossen weiterzumachen sie haben
einen markt mit 500 millionen menschen
geschaffen der etwa 14 prozent des
weltweiten bruttoinlandsprodukts
ausmacht wir sprechen von einem abkommen
das allen mitgliedern die tür zu den
volkswirtschaften von japan australien
kanada neuseeland vietnam mexiko chile
peru brunei malaysia und singapur
praktisch vollständig öffnet
denn liebe visual politik fans das cpp
ist ein sogenanntes handelsabkommen der
neuen generation dh das abkommen
beschränkt sich nicht nur auf die
abschaffung der meisten zölle sondern
konzentriert sich auch auf den abbau und
die liberalisierung nicht karriere
handelshemmnisse und die festlegung
gemeinsamer regeln zu den digitalen
handel beschränkungen für staatliche
unternehmen geistiges eigentum
umweltvorschriften und so weiter und so
fort turiner zeit als die usa mit dabei
waren definierte die obama-regierung es
als ein instrument das die neuen regeln
des welthandels festlegen sollte die
idee dahinter ist dass du wenn du erst
einmal dabei ist praktisch
uneingeschränkte handelsfreiheit
zwischen den verschiedenen
mitgliedsländern genießt und weißt du
was das ist genau das worauf sich die
mitgliedsländer konzentrieren
[Musik]
und das ist noch nicht alles das cbp
zeichnet sich vor allem dadurch aus dass
es der angesagteste der hippste klub der
welt geworden ist großbritannien teil
waren und die volksrepublik china haben
jetzt offiziell einen antrag auf
mitgliedschaft gestellt ja ihr habt euch
nicht verhört die streithähne peking und
taipeh wollen tatsächlich beide
gleichzeitig mitglieder im gleichen club
sein das ist ein unglaublicher
meilenstein für die völkerverständigung
ja den weltfrieden und könnte die chance
für eine echte zeitenwende seien die
einigkeit und den frieden den die
europäische union über 50 jahre lang in
europa bewirkt könnte die bdp nun
ostasien bringen aber auch weit über
diese wirtschaftlich bedeutendste
regionen der welt hinaus südkorea und
wahrscheinlich auch thailand werden
voraussichtlich schon dieses jahr
beitreten beobachter meinen sogar dass
sich die usa dieser welle anschließen
könnten obwohl unser award preisträger
2029 joe biden von dieser idee im moment
nicht sehr begeistert zu sein scheint
tatsache ist dass wir über ein abkommen
sprechen dass handel offenheit und
wirtschaftliche integration wieder ganz
oben auf die tagesordnung viele der
größten volkswirtschaften der welt
gesetzt hat alles mit dem klaren ziel
freie märkte und wettbewerb zu fördern
und wir alle wissen dass dinge die ihr
bei visual politik lieben aber damit
nicht die pferde mit uns allen
durchgehen tatsächlich scheint es
derzeit unwahrscheinlich dass hier
aufgenommen werden könnte weil es viele
dinge an seinem politisch
wirtschaftlichen system ändern müsste
zum beispiel müsste es aufhören
staatsunternehmen massiv subventionieren
und zu bevorzugen sich weniger in
private unternehmen einmischen und den
freien datenverkehr erlauben und die
realität also außer schießen bin kein
großer fan solcher dinge zu sein scheint
[Applaus]
aber wie ihn auch sei es ist klar dass
wir über einen immer einflussreicheren
und größeren klub sprechender der
globalisierung und der weltweiten
wirtschaftlichen integration neuen
schwung verleihen will für all das und
die chance dass handel und freiheit
wieder mehr bedeuten werden als
beschränkungen und grenzen geht unser
dritter visual politik vor 2021 an das
cpp klassischen glückwunsch an alle
mitgliedsländer und viel glück den
bewerbern giorgio lass dir diese chance
nicht entgehen
das waren unsere preisträger des jahres
2021 aber jetzt bist du dran würdest du
dieser liste noch jemanden hinzufügen
bist du mit unserer auswahl
einverstanden oder findest du eine von
ihnen hätte die auszeichnung nicht
verdient wie immer sind sie auf deine
meinung zu diesem thema schon sehr
angespannt bevor wir uns verabschieden
möchten wir euch ein gutes jahr 2022
wünschen und euch noch einmal dafür
danken dass wir uns die ganze zeit über
treu begleitet hat wir sind sehr stolz
darauf dass jeden tag mehr und mehr von
euch hinter diesem projekt stehen unter
deutscher kanal hat heute schon über 80
tausend abonnenten und unsere schwester
kanäle auf spanisch und englisch die
schon etwas länger gibt gas zweieinhalb
beziehungsweise 1,1 millionen und die
visual politik familie wächst weiter im
dezember wurde unser jüngstes baby
geboren welches französisch spricht und
dass wir auf den namen diplom metrix
getauft haben mit anderen worten diese
familie wächst stetig und das bereits in
vier verschiedenen sprachen und da diese
eine frage immer wieder gestellt wird ja
wir sind eine familie
der deutschsprachige kanal musste ich
jedoch eigenständig finanzieren und
natürlich noch etwas zur erstellung der
gemeinsamen inhalte beitragen welche
dann in die jeweilige sprachversion
umgesetzt wir werden also nichts von den
anderen kanälen quersubventioniert
sondern sind auf euch und die sponsoren
angewiesen deshalb möchten wir euch von
ganzem herzen danken wir versprechen
euch dass wir uns auch im jahr 2022
bemühen werden euch mehr und noch
bessere inhalte zu bieten die es
ermöglichen uns nicht zuletzt auch eure
spenden ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat falls ja gibt es bei
gefehlt es euren freunden vergesst nicht
dass aber mit glück keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen und unterstützt
unsere arbeit betrage mit einer kleinen
spende über den link in der beschreibung
unter diesem video macht gut und bis
bald
[Musik]